faire un petit voyage dans le temps
quelques décennies en arrière 1982
olivia newton john trône en tête des
palmarès avec six écoles ça vous donne
une idée
mais surtout c'est une toute nouvelle
console de jeu qui faisait rêver les
jeunes la collec' aux visions jeunes etc
table et se savoure ce rapport que ça
c'est en plein mon époque je peux vous
dire il ya vous rappelez sans doute et
du catalogue de distribution aux
consommateurs oui qu'on recevait à peu
près tous mais le nôtre je peux vous
dire qu'il s'ouvrait à la page que les
couches coleco vision et des autres
consoles comme celle d'atari je me suis
quelqu'un dans la rue j'en avais eu demi
était trop vieux cv d'un stage leur
était quelqu'un juste réunion ou deux de
plus c'est pas les mêmes cercles
enfin ça sert à rien de vouloir se lier
d'amitié avec quelqu'un il vous fera pas
jouer à son os coleco vision mais faut
dire que il y avait des raisons pour
lesquelles les petits garçons de mon âge
et même temps son extrême un bond dans
le futur si on comparait ou console
atari jouer passante pays de noms n'ont
pas toutes être on se rapproche
en fait pour match qu'on trouvait dans
des arcades avec ça c'était le début les
consoles de nouvelle génération donc
avait pas mal plus de couleurs et avait
des jeux qui était intéressant qu'ils
étaient mieux conçus du point de vue
graphique il y avait aussi des effets 3d
qui commençait à se manifester et même
des accessoires qu'on pouvait acheter
pour aller avec le col et cohésion
manière revol à eau et des malades parce
qu'il a peints voilà moi j'ai retrouvé
un de mes anciens camarades du
secondaire qui en avait une elle
non j'avais pas galérer à ce moment là
c'est serge boidevaix je l'appris sur
facebook qui est aujourd'hui directeur
du marketing chez exceldor en banlieue
de montréal donc on y retourner ensemble
trente deux en arrière
au magasin j'avais vu cette machine là
qui vendait comme le temps de la
nouvelle génération plus puissante la
xbox one de l'époque si on veut là qu'il
y avait des plus beaux graphismes et on
rappelle à ta liste des blocs carrés qui
formait des images lui commence à avoir
une idée qu est un personnage
le jeu qui venait avec le colis cost
donkey kong donc l'apparition de mario
mario bros qui montaient des échelles
monter les niveaux qui on pouvait
entrevoir kevin moustache qu'il y avait
une salopette on réussisse à l'imaginer
pineau mois et marsa on s'est attaché
pendant un jeu dans mon côté accent
un vaisseau qui dans une espèce de
décors 3d
je pense être dans les premiers juste
qu'on voyait vraiment une vue par les
trois encore en élévation ton vaisseau
se déplacer latéralement mais en hauteur
aussi l'habitude à l'époque les justes
est juste du 2d l'on avait vraiment une
petite impression de 3d il fallait
passer par dessus des murets et c'est
une console qui pouvait être dit ont
agrémenté de quelques modules
supplémentaires on pouvait ajouter avec
la colique aux visions exactement l'un
des premiers modules c'est un module
carrément pour jouer des cassettes atari
pas besoin de l'acheter mon ami avec la
console
l'autre module que j'achète et elle est
superman est que je définis presque
encore comme le contrôleur quasi idéale
notamment avec un bouton par toi et avec
l'autre main dessus manipuler le
joystick qui était sur le dessus le jeu
qui menait avec son jeu de baseball
je vais devoir probablement un des jeux
où on a plus joué
et le troisième module magret c'est un
gros moteur c'est un ordinateur qui
s'appelait adam avec imprimante qu'on
peut appeler mitraillette c'est une
espèce d'imprimantes un marteau quand
l'imprimante par terre la conversation
était terminée très très bruyante
je devais rajoute évidemment tu étais
accents la mitaine parce que
l'imprimante était anglophone fait que
on sortait le disque rayons et on
écrivait de l'élise action ils y restent
entre eux pour vous à la maison
longtemps et un manège tourne mais non
mais mes parents n'avaient disposent-ils
si vos parents ont en effet disposé et
que vous retourniez chez eux aujourd'hui
qu'il leur encore est ce que vous le
branchez riez sûrement pleurer essayer
voir si les souvenirs sont aussi beaux
est ce qu'on a dans notre tête parce que
ça peut être douteux
mais est ce qu a duré de vie de la
collection vision sa carrière était
plutôt courtrai les ordinateurs
personnels sont arrivés à l'inter s80
les commodore 64
certains lui a quand même eu pendant
tous deux sont secondaires il a appris à
programmer là dessus si vous avez des
souvenirs liés à la colecovision elle et
lui allaient dont les écrire et les
partager sur la page facebook des
limites merci beaucoup je n'ai que
tremblay y compris